[Music]
What creatures will you meet when you go
see the new movie Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves
oh that's not good
will there be an album what is that
again the mashup that somehow carries
all of the terror with none of the cute
from owls and bears
we're mimics monsters that composes
anything
will there be a gelatinous cube that
disarms its victims how about a
displacer beast a predator with
tentacles and cloaking abilities and
well isn't that more than enough
a giant brain that consumes other brains
like some kind of awful brain cannibal
the higher the intelligence the prey the
more likely they are to strike
oh that's a little hurtful or even
tempered shot the red dragon who looks
like he ate all the other dragons as
appetizers
you'll just have to go see Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves to find out
foreign
okay chop it off chop it off let's do it
oh we got him now
you know what I'm thinking they're
probably sharper stairs somewhere else
we're thieves but we helped the wrong
person steal the wrong thing and unleash
the greatest evil the world has ever
known
the red Wizards created an army of the
undead
sounds lovely quite the opposite I know
I was being ironic I find irony as a
blade because he who wields it most
especially you're not a lot of fun are
you
how are we gonna pull this off more than
I need a team
follow me to the orifice
the orifice
I'll go lost
I don't mind that
he missed
no that's not good
aren't you sick of failing we could die
it's worse things than dying
I lost everything that ever mattered to
me and if we quit now that's for nothing
I don't want to see you die which is why
I'm Gonna Leave the Room
this ends now
the bridge is protected by an ancient
trap we must not trigger the mechanism
I may have triggered the mechanism
so
sorry
[Music]